Hi, Guardians
Are you ready for one last ride?
Let's give the galaxy
something to remember us by.
Drax, Sit up here for Drax.
It's called a sofa.
It's not a bed. Well I find it hard to believe.
it doesn’t have multiple purposes.
Doesn't really matter, does it?
I'm sorry.
My friend is stupid. I'm hungry.
All right?
I want you all to know that I am grateful
to fight beside my friends.
He didn't want to make things perfect.
He just hated things.
The way they are
We were always searching for a family
until we found each other.
Are you ready
for one last ride?
We'll fly away together
into the forever
that beautiful sky.
Knock if off! What. I just noticed how black
Your eyes were.
They were replaced by my father
as a method of torture.
He. He picked a pretty set.
Welcome back
everyone it’s Charlie. Marvel dropped
a brand new Guardians of the Galaxy
three trailer with a bunch of new footage
that will break it down.
There's a bunch of Easter eggs.
If you're brand new to the channel, be
sure to subscribe to get all the videos.
We're getting ready
for our Secret Invasion episodes too.
Of course I'll do videos for all those.
Well,
just starting with the brand new stuff,
we see a new shot of Gamora
having one of those same types
of milk drinks
that Rocket is drinking
later in the trailer.
All explain their drinks in a second too,
because it's a bit of a funny Easter egg,
especially if you're a huge fan of Marvel
from back in the day.
This also serves to give us a better look
inside the Guardians new ship, the Bowie,
which is like the brand new suit
that they had as of the holiday
special in the Guardians of the Galaxy
Holiday Special.
We saw a little bit
more of it when Drax and Mantis took it
to go back to Earth to steal Kevin Bacon.
It's meant to be a huge upgrade
over their previous ships.
The Milano than the Benatar.
Like each time they get a slightly nicer,
slightly bigger ship,
it's kind of like Iron Man
getting new armors in all of his movies.
The Guardians get new ships,
we get the new shot of Rocket
in front of this fridge here.
The funny Easter egg here
is that it seems like he's drinking in
Gomorrah is also drinking space milk
because the writing on the fridge
behind him
zoom in enhanced is in the Cree language
and it translates to milk
because the main villain of Guardians of
the Galaxy three is the high evolutionary.
This is also meant to be
a bit of a deep cut Easter egg for bova,
one of the high revolutionaries creations
who was a huge part of Scarlet Witch
in Quicksilver's origin story.
Also, the whole idea you get milk
from cows were in space.
So they're space cows.
One of the space cows in the Marvel
Universe is Boba in the comics
high evolutionary. His whole thing,
as you see during the trailers,
is creating human animal hybrids.
But originally
his main base was on planet Earth,
which is how he runs into Quicksilver
and Scarlet Witch.
When they were children,
One of his earliest creations was Boba.
There was also an Easter egg for her
during one division in the supermarket
during the opening credits,
because that series was all about Scarlet
Witch with a little bit of Quicksilver.
Not quite the Quicksilver
we were expecting.
So Magneto is Scarlet
Witch and Quicksilver's father.
He has them with his wife, Magda.
But after they're born,
afraid of what will happen to Magneto
because he is Magneto.
Everyone wants to kill him,
and he's kind of dangerous himself.
Magda flees to mount one day Gora nearby
with the twins who are still newborns.
The high revolutionaries
base used to be on Mount One.
Diggory There was an Easter egg for Matt,
one to go during Doctor
Strange Multiverse of Madness.
That was the place where Katherine built
the Darkhold Temple in the MCU.
So Magna flees to Mount one
to Gore to visit the high evolutionary
asks for sanctuary for the twins,
which he denies.
Bova then gives them to the Maximoff,
which is why Quicksilver
Scarlet Witch have the last name Maximoff.
They're Wanda and Pedro Maximoff.
They don't carry the Lynch surname
for their real father.
Bova had been one of the revolutionaries
earliest experiments
and became one of his knights of one day.
Gorr One of the more powerful groups
initially.
And eventually he decides
that he couldn't push his science,
his experiments
any further on planet Earth.
And that's when he gets the idea
to create Counter Earth,
which is the place
we see in all the trailers here
with the human animal hybrids like this
freakish looking version of Earth, because
it is quote unquote, counter Earth.
I'm assuming his evolutionary backstory
will be a little bit different in the MCU
because in the comics, he started out
as a regular human scientist.
His name was Herbert Edgar Windom.
There was an Easter egg for him
in Guardians of the Galaxy two,
the planet that they crash on
at the beginning of the movie,
right after they run into ego.
The living Planet is.
Berger That's meant to be
an anagram of Herbert Edgar Wyndham.
So it's like James Gunn was giving us
a little spoiler Easter egg there.
Spoiler.
I'm going to be doing
the High Evolutionary in my next movie.
There's a new scene of Rocket
piloting the Bowie,
which seems like it's happening
a little bit earlier in the movie.
Then there's a new scene of Adam Warlock
beating the hell out of Nebula on nowhere.
And in the background, there's another
huge Easter egg zoom enhance.
There's a sign this Also in the Cree
language, it translates to Thomas.
It's meant to be an Easter egg
for Roy Thomas, the comic book creator
who co-created the Adam Warlock character
who is now
beating the hell out of the Guardians,
just like in the comics.
His whole thing, as he says in
the trailer, is trying
to create the perfect life for him,
and he just feels like
humans aren't up to the task,
which is why he starts
creating these human animal hybrids.
Thus he creates beings like rocket,
even though they play this scene for
comedy like Drax, just trying to chill out
like it's a couch.
Why shouldn't they lie on it?
Everything is meant to look like
it's from your grandma's house.
That she hasn't changed
in the last 50 years.
Like the high evolutionary
wants everything on counter Earth to look
quintessentially American, like old school
American.
There's a bunch of deep cuts
from the comics here too,
so we'll see if they wind up using
a version of Man Beast in the movie, too,
because it's a huge part of Adam Warlock
origin story and how he wound up
getting the soul stone in his forehead.
Now he does have a gem on his forehead
in all the trailers,
but that's probably just tied to the way
that his power works in the MCU.
He doesn't have an infinity stone
in the MCU, but like you look on the walls
in the background, they have more human
looking people in stock photos.
Just everything is made
to look hilariously American.
There's more footage of Groot going
into what they're calling his Kaiju form.
They're calling him Kaiju Groot.
So like the thick, small version of Groot,
the Chad version of Groot
is going to be called Kaiju.
Groot They also revealed that he can grow
wings in Fly, which is a brand new thing.
His powers in the comics
are kind of nebulous, though
he can pretty much do anything
that you could conceive of doing
with plants, trees, biological matter
or wood, just in general.
And if it wasn't clear from the previous
Guardians of the Galaxy movies
or even the Thor movies
since he got stormbreaker like in Avengers
Infinity War, in Avengers Endgame,
the wood that grows from Roots
body is super hard
compared to normal trees.
That's part of the reason
why Stormbreaker so strong.
Like the metal, the enchantments on it
that were created by the dwarves, by E3
are really strong, but also the handle
from Roots Body makes it super strong.
The whole thing with Adam
Warlock in the movie is
his body is coursing with that annual ax.
Battery energy, which is baked into
his body, are used in the sovereign
create those batteries.
They're a big part of the plot
during the Guardians of the Galaxy
two movie, it looks like some of their
energy is based on quantum energy, too.
Like they're just meant
to be incredibly powerful batteries.
They basically just
bake that technology into his body
and that's how he creates those energy.
Swords like you see Drax
grab one and try to stop him.
That seems like an extension
of one of his powers.
Like he kind of creates
the MCU version of a light saber.
He can give it off and blast
it coursing all over his body.
And it's also probably how he can fly.
Like he uses it the way Iron Man would use
repulsive technology.
Except he doesn't wear a special suit
to generate the energy.
It just comes from his body.
It probably has something to do
with the gem in his forehead.
Just like a lot of his powers
in the comics are tied to the gem
in his forehead, which in the comics
are usually the sole gem.
This the big thing about Adam Warlock
is that it
usually gave him the name Adam
during the second Guardians
of the Galaxy Post-Credits scene,
but nobody has called him Warlock yet.
That'll probably wind up happening
in this movie.
Early theory
is that he'll just do something crazy
with his powers, and one of the characters
will call him a warlock because of that.
Usually in the comics though,
he started out being called Warlock
and then eventually later
one of the beings on Counter Earth
that he helped save when he was getting
the soul gem from the high
evolutionary called him Adam.
But in that case it was meant to be more
of a biblical reference because the story
that was taking place in
was more of a reference to Bible stories.
But James gets it.
They're playing him in this movie
the same way they played vision
in Avengers Age of Ultron,
like a born yesterday kind of vibe
where he totally does not understand
what's going on.
But he's meant to be nigh invincible.
Like he has crazy powers, but
just has no concept of what's going on,
no real understanding of good and evil,
and that will just continue in the future.
That'll be a big part of his arc.
In the same way that vision pondered
morality during Avengers
Age of Ultron, we get more flashback
scenes with the high evolutionary.
It actually seems like we see a couple
of different versions of the character,
like one of them has hair,
and then in the later footage you see him
with his skin all pulled back
like he's been upgraded even more.
That's actually right out of the comics.
The whole idea with the character
is that he started out as a regular human.
Herbert Windham,
and then slowly upgraded himself in.
The reason why he wears a mask
is because he messed up his face
so bad while he was upgrading himself.
So all the footage of him
in this tank here
looks like him getting ready
to upgrade Rocket in the past.
Like this is a flashback of Rocket's
origin story.
You also see the high evolutionary
looking like he hasn't upgraded himself
quite as much either,
so that in present day,
when they see him on counter
Earth, he looks way different because
he's giving himself way more powers.
That's
also another thing about the character.
He's meant to be super powerful,
but his powers are also kind of nebulous.
He continually upgrades himself
to give himself more powers
and make himself more powerful.
He's even been able to fight
beings like Galactus, like that's
how powerful he gets.
They don't show you a ton of his powers
in the trailers.
We only see him use telekinesis
and it looks like he can also fly,
but he has way more powers than that.
They also some brand new footage
from a separate 40 x trailer where you see
Nebula
inside the cockpit of the Bowie ship
and it looks like the revolutionary
has done something to disable it.
Somehow
there's energy parking all over the room.
It just seems like it's when they
eventually encounter him in the movie.
If you spotted any other Easter eggs
or references in the brand new trailer
footage
that I didn't talk about in the video,
just write them below in the comments
and they'll be more trailers
because we're getting really close
to the movie coming out.
James Gunn did say we started
seeing some more footage pretty soon.
Also a big reminder, the next big
Marvel series is coming out on Disney.
Plus will be Secret Invasion.
They've delayed that to June.
Now that will be like the next big thing
that happens
after Guardians of the Galaxy
three also are doing more videos for that.
When we get more trailer footage,
it should be in the next month or so.
Right now I'm currently in the middle
of doing Mandalorian Season three videos.
You can click here for that
brand new Mandalorian Season three Episode
six Video
Update the link
As soon as I post that and click here
for that brand new Deadpool
three trailer video and learn
about the two Wolverines
that are supposed to be in the movie.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one.